في السادس من سبتمبر من العام 2018 وافق
البرلمان الاوكراني على مشروع قانون
لتعديل بعض القوانين لضمان المساواه في
الحقوق والفرص بين النساء والرجال اثناء
الخدمه العسكريه في القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه حيث تخدم الان اكثر من خمسين
الف امراه في الجيش الاوكراني 37 منهن
عسكريا وثلاثه عشر الفا في الجيش في مناصب
اداريه ومدنيه في الوقت الذي تقاتل ما
يزيد عن الخمسه الاف مقاتله في خطوط النار
الاماميه من بينهن ضابطات
التي سماها الروس بالقناصه الفاشيه
الاوكرانيه كانت قبل الحرب سيده اعمال
تمارس صناعه الحلي الا انها كانت تهوى
القنصه وتمارسه منذ الطفوله
قبل الحرب الشامله على اوكرانيا كنت امراه
عاديه وكان لدي الرؤيه الخاص لقد كانت لدي
حياه رائعه وناجحه وكانت لدي كثير من
الخطط الحياتيه جنسنا
الى صفوف القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
كمتطوعه للدفاع عن بلادها عند بدايه الحرب
وانخرطت في تدريبات مكثفه للقناصه مستفيده
من خبرتها في الرمايه والقنص حتى اصبحت من
القناصه القلائل الذين توكل اليهم مهام
قتاليه في اخطر واصعب الجبهات
كنت ارغب بالذهاب الى القتال قبل عشره
اعوام عندما انتهيت من دراسه العسكريه
وحصلت على تعليمي العسكري لذلك الان عندما
قررت كان من السهل علي الالتحاق بالجيش
كنت محظوظه ان اذهب الى القناصه
لم تتوقف الاثاره في حياه القناصه
الاوكرانيه في الجبهه عند القتال والمعارك
الضاريه بل امتدت الى حياتها الشخصيه حيث
عثرت على حب حياتها هناك الضابط الذي تقدم
لخطبتها في خط النار حيث عقد قرانهما في
الادغال
تعرفت على زوجي عن طريق وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي فقد كنا في الويه مختلفه وخدمنا
في ولايه مختلفه بعد اسبوعين حضر للتعرف
على قائد واخبرهم الا يقلقوا وانه عسكري
وشخص جيد وستكون قناصتهم بخير معه وتقدم
في ذات اليوم لخطبتي فعليا لقد كانت تلك
المره الثانيه التي نلتقي فيها وتزوجنا في
خط النار مباشره لقد كان ذلك سريعا
ورومانسيا جدا وبعد ان تزوجت نشر الاعلام
الروسي ووصفني باشهر قناصه فاشيه اوكرانيه
تزوجت
من عنصري اخر مثلها لا تختلف عن قصص كثير
من النساء في الخطوط الاماميه منهن قائدات
لراجمات الصواريخ والدبابات وقائدات
طائرات دون طيار ومسعفات طبيه في اكثر
المناطق سخونه تمثل النساء في القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه 22 بالمئه وهي واحده
من اعلى المعدلات بين جيوش الدول
الاوروبيه ضيف عادل العربيه كيف